Jackie Burkhardt was a career defining
role for Mila Kunis but there's
something she finds unnerving About That
70s Show regarded as one of the funniest
sitcoms in TV history That 70s Show
appeals to audiences young and old with
its nostalgic subject matter and
endearing portrayal of Teenage life as
such it's no wonder that the show's
immense popularity helped launch the
careers of its young cast which included
the likes of Ashton Kutcher Wilmer
Valderrama Laura Prepon Topher Grace and
of course Mila Kunis Kunis in particular
has enjoyed an enormous amount of
success since her breakout role as
Jackie Burkhart in That 70s Show scoring
a recurring role on Family Guy as the
voice of Meg Griffin and starring in
prolific films such as Forgetting Sarah
Marshall Black Swan and the Book of Eli
considering the many notable and
successful projects she has been
involved in since the 2006 conclusion of
That 70s Show it might surprise some
fans to learn that she actually refuses
to watch the series for one admittedly
understandable reason
during an appearance on the happy sad
confused podcast in October 2022 Mila
Kunis confessed that she has never
actually seen a full episode of That 70s
Show the actor went on to explain that
she finds it too odd to see her most
awkward teenage years preserved on
camera for all to watch Kunis's
reluctance makes sense when considering
the fact that she infamously lied about
her age to join That 70s Show jumping
onto the main cast when she was just 14
years old where most people might get
away with simply avoiding old yearbook
photos or trying not to remember their
awkward phases from high school Kunis
has several full seasons of Television
that document her teenage years still
while she may prefer not to spend a lot
of time revisiting her adolescence the
actor isn't completely opposed to giving
That 70s Show a shot as she explained if
it ever goes back to broadcast and if it
comes on then I think I'd watch it while
Mila Kunis hasn't watched That 70s Show
it doesn't appear to have anything to do
with her experience working on the show
itself in fact the actor has spoken
quite positively about the filming
environment for the series she shared in
an interview with Vanity Fair I had the
greatest experience on 70s 100 I was
embraced I was never treated as like
lesser than and if I did by one of the
cast members another cast member would
stand up for it Kunis also talked about
how difficult it was to leave the show
behind when it came time for the finale
in 2006. Kuna said on The Ellen Show on
the day I couldn't stop crying I
literally reverted to being a little kid
and I just wanted someone to hold me but
while the program may have ended the
story of Jackie Burkhart didn't though
it took over a decade and a half for the
opportunity to arise Mila Kunis didn't
turn down the chance to play the iconic
character once again she and her husband
Ashton Kutcher who portrayed Michael
Kelso in the original series returned to
their classic roles for Netflix's 2023
spin-off bat 90s show Jackie and Kelso
pop up in the first episode of season
one appropriately titled that 90s pilot
with the latter giving kurtwood Smith's
red formant a headache for old time's
sake while Kunis admitted to Access
Hollywood that it was a strange
experience to be filming opposite her
husband once again she lavished Praise
on the overall production prior to the
show's debut the actress said it's very
sweet it's it pays homage to anyone
who's ever watched 70s or loved 70s Show
they will be really happy with it at the
same time considering that Jackie ends
up with Wilmer valderrama's Fez in the
That 70s Show finale Kunis does find it
a bit odd that Jackie and Kelso are an
item in that 90s show at the end of the
day even though she hasn't gone back to
watch it That 70s Show will always
remain a standout part of Mila Kunis's
career and pop culture Legacy
thank you
foreign